- So many women are dealing
with life after divorce.
I know because I am one of them
Adjusting to a new life, it is not easy.
It takes almost years to
figure out how to navigate it.
And it's a taboo subject.
And here on this show,
we wanna be gentle and we
wanna figure things out
and we wanna support each other
and learn from each other's
life experiences and wisdom.
And with that,
I wanna introduce Louanna,
who is currently dealing with divorce.
Please take a look.
- Hi Drew, this is Louanna.
I'm going through a really
tough divorce situation
right now,
and I know you've been
through the same thing.
I've been married for 11 years,
separated for three years,
I have three beautiful children,
but I think everything's
just in limbo right now.
I mean the pandemic has put a hold
on every single thing
that needs to be done.
I'm just,
I'm a single mom and I'm
just trying to stay positive.
I'm taking it one day at a time,
counting my blessings each and every day.
But I know that you can help me.
So could we please talk about this?
(audience clapping)
Louanna I would be
honored to talk about it.
Hi, how are you?
(audience clapping)
- Hello, hello.
Good morning.
Thank you for having me.
- I'm gonna just start
right out of the gate
and say that your smiling
eyes and your tone,
tone is a big thing with me,
and it's synonymous with energy.
- [Louanna] Right.
- And your energy is clearly
seeking the light here
and wherever it took you
to get to where you are,
you are in a place
where you are projecting
and radiating strength and light.
So I commend you for the
immense amount of work
it must've taken you to get
where you are right now.
- It has been a journey, but
I'm happy that I'm here now.
I always told myself that
there is a light at the end
of the tunnel,
and I just have to feel to heal.
So I was open to feeling
any pain, any happiness,
any ups and downs, any joy,
whatever I felt that day,
I made sure to feel it
at a hundred percent
just so I know that I
went through the journey
to get me to where I am right now.
- How long were you married may I ask?
- I was married for 11 years
and kind of still right?
'Cause you know, the
divorce is still pending.
I'm in limbo.
And so I am still married,
but I was together with
my ex for about 11 years.
- And how long has it been
since you've been separated?
- About three, about three,
maybe going into four
'cause my youngest
daughter is four years old.
So yeah, since then.
- And where, divorce papers aside,
where do you feel like
you're at in the journey?
Do you still feel like
everything is as raw and fresh
as if it was yesterday,
or do you feel like the
ship is leaving the dock
a little bit?
The ship has almost left the dock.
I can't say that I'm a
hundred percent there,
but I certainly do not
feel the same way as I did
a few years back.
So time does heal and I'm
happy that I'm here now.
- I'm so glad to hear you
say that because everybody
said that to me, time.
I think the way you described
it was really good and it, it,
I think what nobody talks
about is that it's gonna take
probably a lot more time
than you really want it to
or anticipate.
- Yes it does take a little bit longer,
because we are as mothers,
we have that connection
with their fathers,
so we can't really say it's
out of sight out of mind.
We still have that connection.
We still have to interact with them.
So it does take a little bit longer,
and but as long as it,
you'll get to where you need to go,
then it should be fine.
- I think it takes such
a intricately woven art
to navigate divorce with
children and how we talk
to those children and
how we work with our exes
in front of them or to them.
How are you doing with that part?
- It was difficult in the
beginning because my emotions
and my feelings were so strong,
but I had to keep thinking to myself,
especially from advice
from family and friends
that keep your children
the number one priority.
What is best for them,
and that's what you should do.
Not to say that you have to
forget about your feelings,
but just keep them number one.
Make sure what they see is positivity
and that no matter what
the differences are,
and we do have differences,
you know co-parenting difficulties
that we have disagreements
about a lot of things.
For example, education.
I'm the big believer in sending
my kids to Catholic school,
where he isn't.
So there's one disagreement,
but we have to act as
adults and he and I have
to be very mature and just
kind of do that on the side,
and it's almost like putting up a show.
And my kids are probably
too young to even understand
what I'm saying right now,
but you're kind of
putting, putting a front,
you know in front of
them just to make sure
that they're seeing the
positive vibes going on.
- I know that this is so hard,
but I think you're at an amazing place,
a really inspirational place
that I'm sure took years
and really hard work to get to.
- Yes, that I could definitely agree too.
And I take a lot of my strength
from the women who I know
are with me on this,
'cause I know there are
women out there who feel
the same way as I do.
And I know that I have a team
backing me up just like you.
I know you're behind me and
I'm behind you all the way,
and we support each other.
So I take a lot of my
strength from the other women
around me and the other women who I know
are going through the same thing,
(upbeat music)